[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us we know
that that is true
many students have spent this past year
going to class virtually
raising significant concerns about a
growing inequality gap
but some groups of high school students
are finding ways to bridge that divide
even as most school districts reopen
safely by teaching what they've learned
to
younger students jan crawford has their
stories
then suddenly dump some ink
for most of first and all of second
grade eight-year-old ella's classroom
has been
the computer the sound is coming
you shouldn't hide behind this screen
and her virginia home this morning
we felt so tired it's the voice that's
kept alive
ella's joy of learning my teeter's name
is miss emily she's kind
and really really sweet i love her so
much
miss emily is 18 year old emily kalt
a high school senior in new york city
when my guidance counselor at my school
told me about this opportunity to
tutor online i started tutoring her
reading and her reading has improved so
much
she's excited to just read everything
peggy
is my best friend ella and emily
connected through
intuitively one of dozens of free online
tutoring programs that was started last
spring
by high school students as high school
students
we understand the struggles of virtual
learning intuitery was created by two
virginia teenagers
alex and his younger brother ben we were
just dismayed to find
that there was an entire generation that
would be forced to play catch up
perhaps for years to come we wanted to
do something
to help bridge that gap what did you do
how did it start we reached out to our
friends classmates and family members
and in the early days we had more tutors
and students how many do you have now
so we have over a thousand um students
and tutors
and about 500 each and since the gulf
war is a problem matches like these
are happening and other free online
tutoring programs
also started after the lockdowns by
teenagers
like edukov run by ian subida joyce and
christian in new york we basically came
up with this idea to connect students
as a way to promote you know social
exchange which was something we all
were missing um with online learning it
was just word of mouth and then constant
just more contacting
and i think as of now we have around 60
to 70 tooties
their mission also was personally i had
an
up close view of this with my two
younger brothers
they were in sixth and fourth grade at
the time and they were really struggling
their focus it sometimes wanes with
virtual school it's harder to keep on
track
and it left them a little bit behind
with math and english
jason is christian's youngest brother an
in-person school
you know the teacher would walk around
the classroom and talking to individuals
but then in online
the teacher would teach the whole
classroom one time one session
and there's no group work these
teenagers may have first
signed on to help others but soon
realized
teaching taught them a different lesson
educove it was an opportunity for me to
find something to really
put my mind into and to really dedicate
myself
into and it really filled the hole that
was sort of left in my heart by
not being able to go to school it's been
hard to deal with the isolation
it's the one thing that really pulled me
through the pandemic okay
ella gives a heart for you having this
bond with ella
she's not someone i would have met
normally and i
really appreciate that super sparkly
subject for cbs this morning
i'm jan crawford in washington history
of sparkle grove forest oh i want to
stay with the history of spark will grow
yeah me too i love hearing kids read
it's just so cool
but how about those high school students
yes so impressive saw a need and thought
we can do something about this
and so many all over yeah i know it's
real initiative too i mean to go from no
students to a full slate making a
difference